What is going on everyone? Welcome back
to another highly anticipated video. In
today's video, we're going to be
covering the very simple, very lucrative
initial balance by rejection strategy. I
just want to make this clear. This is
not something that I came up with on my
own. This is directly from Edgeold, the
data provider, which I will link down in
the description if you want to go check
them out.
Jumping right into it. The initial
balance is very similar to the 15-minute
orb.
15-minute orb strategy, you chart the
high and low of that first 15-minute
candle, which I'm sure many of you guys
watching this video have heard of or
used before. For the initial bounce
strategy or the initial bounce by
rejection strategy, you're charting out
the first 60 minutes of market open 9:30
to 10:30 a.m. EST.
The low and the high formed in that time
gives you your range that you're
therefore targeting for a breakout.
The example on the left here is going to
be a bullish break. The example on the
right is going to be a bearish break.
I'm going to cover exactly why that is,
how I use them, what the downside is,
what the upside is coming right up.
Jumping to the chart now. We're looking
at December 19th, 2025. This is going to
be a replay because this is the perfect
example of how the strategy is supposed
to work.
Jumping directly into open. This is 9:30
open on Friday, December 19th. We want
to see what low or high of that range is
formed first. In this case, we formed a
low with a little teeny tiny wick at
61192.
Jumping to the next couple of candles,
we formed the high at 61760.
61762.
And then we completely form the initial
bounce at 10:30 with that 10:15 candle
closing right at about 6:1540.
That is our range that we are trading
for the day. Going over to Edgeful,
we're looking at what the stat is
telling us should happen for the day. In
this case, we form the low first.
60-minute IB low formed first. That
means that we have a 72% chance of
breaking the high. And this is measured
Monday through Friday. If you want to go
and refine it down to a specific
weekday, you just go and unselect
whichever one you want. In this case,
we're looking at a Friday. And this
tells us what the stat should be. We're
looking at a 61.5% chance on a Friday.
I'm going to break down how you can use
these stats even better later in the
video, so stick around. So, we have
significance in targeting the high
breakout.
Where do you enter, though? I know that
it should go and break the high. But
what happens if it ends up just chopping
for the remaining two hours, three
hours, goes all the way down to the low
and then breaks the high?
This is where the most simple part of
the strategy comes in. You're entering
as close to 50% of the initial balance
as possible. If I go down to the five
minute time frame here, this gives us a
little bit better of an entry. We know
that the initial balance is finalized at
10:30. There's no more range high, no
more range low. If we're looking at, in
this case about a $5 range,
and we know that this candle closes in a
couple of minutes, that's the initial
balance formed. We know our entry is as
close to 50% of the initial balance as
possible. IB50,
you can frontr run it a little bit,
which is what I often do. I enter
sometimes at 10:25, sometimes at 1028,
sometimes even at 10:23. If the candle
has about seven minutes left in it, I'm
okay with entering. It's also dependent
on the range. So, if we have a range
like we did on Thursday earlier this
week, where it's also significantly
choppy,
not really looking to frontr run it all
that much, more so just observing. I'll
get a lower riskreward on the trade. The
basis of this trade comes with a
onetoone riskreward. So, if I want to
enter this position knowing that it
should go and target the long or the
upside,
I'm looking for a takerit at the high
and my stop loss is an invalidation of
the initial bounce, which is going to be
a break of the low. So, that's my
entrance right there, right at 50% of
the IB. Skip to the next couple of
candles here. We can see that price kind
of just hovered there. And even after
10:30, it gave I mean a picture perfect
entry at 50% of the IB. That wick went
maybe two cents past 50%.
So let's say we entered right there.
Drag this candle out a little bit more.
And this one took quite a while to go
and develop.
We never really got close to our stop
loss. We never got more than 50% of that
IB. And if we continue pushing into the
later half that day, price action was
choppy. I'm going to cover what else
happened during this day that is
significantly
uh appealing to the strategy. We can see
that the longer we go, yes, we're in the
trade for a very long time here. It just
about took the IB high right there. Now,
this is going over to MNQ, which is what
I trade. This is 128 point move that it
made from 50% of the IB with maybe 20
points in draw down.
As soon as I get about 35 to 50 points
in the green, I put my stop loss at
break even. So, I'm no longer risking
anything on the trade. And I let it run
to either the full TP or I trail my stop
loss typically 25 to 35 points behind
it. And either I get stopped out 200,
300, $400 in the green or I hit the full
TP at the initial balance breakout. That
is how I go about entering the strategy.
That's how I trade the strategy every
single day.
Some days you have choppy price action
like this where the initial bounce
formed quite literally with one minute
left. It went and took a new high. Never
really offered an opportunity to enter.
This one I just watched and this was the
first time that I didn't take the
initial bounce by rejection strategy for
maybe three months.
Every single day this pops up. every
single day you usually get a retracement
back to 50% of the IB whether it's at
9:45 10 o'clock or even at 10:30 like
this happened here right at 10:25 10:30
perfect retracement to 50% of the IB and
then it went right down to the bottom so
yet again what you're doing you're
entering a short position in this case
because the IB high was formed first the
IB low was formed second so you're
targeting the low your entrance is right
at 50% stop loss at the IB high,
take-profit at the break of the IB low.
This one happened in maybe 3 minutes, 5
minutes, went all the way down to the IB
below. Had a beautiful continuation,
which you can play. I prefer to just
trade the initial balance breakout
rather than trade a continuation of it.
That's for another video. But again, as
price moves up, I like to trail my stop
at least to break even. Usually trail it
in the profit and then
have it hit full TP or it takes me out
with a trailing stop loss about 25 to 30
points behind. That is essentially how
you trade it. And we had last week we
had two picture perfect entries. Uh
Friday, December 19th and Wednesday,
December 17th. And it doesn't really
matter how many days you want to go
back. It happens every single trading
day because every trading day you're
going to have a 60-minute range
established. Now, some days
takes a lot longer to go and break that
initial balance report.
Uh Tuesday, December 16th, we formed the
high and then formed the low. We had an
entrance right at 60973.
This one took two and a half hours to go
and break. It did break the IB low as
expected and then it went and took the
high. Looking at the stat on this trade
and if I go to every single weekday
here,
Monday through Friday, the trade itself
has about a 73% win rate. Once this pops
up, 73 to 75. This is over the past six
months. If I go to the past three years,
this is going to take a little bit to
load, but while it pops up, I'll go and
look at some more examples here. You can
see just how many days of the week we
have a retracement to 50% which is where
your entry is. You have a perfect one to
one riskreward on the trade and your
takeprofits at the low or the high
depending on which one forms first. Now
going over that uh data point that I
added in on Friday and again on Monday,
we never went and broke that IB.
Although we did trend to the direction
that we were targeting and then
ultimately broke it after hours. We
never broke it during trading hours,
which if you're worried about that
happening often, we go to just the
regular initial balance report, the
standard one.
This only ever happens 2% of the time
once the report pulls up. Sorry for the
delay here.
this event where you don't have the
initial balance report break or the
initial balance range 618 to uh 609 in
this case and then 611 to 617 on Friday.
This happens a mere 2 to 3% of the time.
Two out of these last four over the past
127 days have been in the past week. So
prior to last week, this had a 1.6%
chance of happening. now has a 3.15%.
Every single day or 97% of the time,
you're going to have a break of the
initial balance. That's why this report
is so reliable. Some days you don't get
your retracement up to 50%. But what
that does is it just mitigates what your
riskreward is on the trade. This is
still a short position. I'm still
looking for a pullback off of the
initial balance report.
Sorry, initial balance range. Keep
saying report. and that's your stop
loss. So, it is a negative riskreward
when you don't get a retracement to 50%.
Still a winning trade. Uh for some days,
you're going to have losses. Obviously,
I just covered this is about a 73% win
rate for each trading day. 73 72
depending on which high or lows form
first. Some days you're going to have a
loss. So, how do you go and avoid that
loss? you go down to, and if we know
that it's about a 73% win rate each day,
what I do is I go down to each
individual weekday. So, I'm going to
look at Monday.
So, again, 73%, keep that number in
mind. If Monday is telling us that we
have a 60% chance of going and breaking
the low since the high was formed first,
that's today, uh, Monday, December 22nd.
I'll exit replay mode here.
We went and took the low. So the stat
still fulfilled itself. But what this is
saying 73% as opposed to 60% it means
that it's overdue a win.
In the same sentence or the same thought
if we go and see a weekday that has
take a look at Friday. It says 83.3% as
opposed to the average at 73%.
This just means it's overdue a loss. So,
flip the script. 60% overdo a win, 83%
overdue a loss. It doesn't mean go and
inverse the data every time. It varies
from the average. It just means that
some days you're going to be overdo a
win, some days you're going to be
overdue a loss. Maybe don't take it for
that day. You might avoid a loss. If you
end up missing out on a win,
no risk, no harm in that position. If
you end up missing out on a loss, you
just saved yourself a couple hundred
bucks or a green day.
The beautiful thing about this stat is
you can also go and use it for spy if
you don't like trading cues. SPY does
the same thing. As you can see today,
initial bounce high form first, initial
initial bounce low second. Went and took
the low. Obviously, we swept it and then
had a double break when it took the
high. I am done trading as soon as price
breaks the initial balance. I do not
care if it continues down another $4. I
do not care if it goes up and has a
double break for the day. I am done as
soon as the initial balance is broken.
So 10:30, 11 o'clock. Some days
like on cues last week, obviously it
didn't break on Friday. Thursday
took who knows how long. Um Tuesday last
week took two and a half hours as I
previously stated. So that is exactly
how I go and use this initial balance
report. Again, if it is significantly
over the average, my rule is 8% over
whatever the average is over the past
six months. If the average over the past
six months is 75%, that means either
83% or if the stats reading 67% I will
not take the trade or I will even
inverse the trade.
Whatever the average is over six months,
8% that's my rule. That is how I have
achieved
five, six payouts over the past couple
of months. And that is just off of five,
six sets of payouts. Those are over five
accounts each time I take it. And that
is as simple of a strategy as it gets.
There's no complicated inverse fair
value gap. Uh the indicator that is on
my screen, this is something that is
offered directly from Edgeel. Again, I
will be linking them in the description
if you guys are interested.
If you made it this far in the video, I
deeply apologize for the voice cracks.
Apparently, my voice did not want to
work correctly today. Hopefully, you
guys enjoyed that. You learned a little
something. Uh, as I said, if you don't
like trading Q's, you can go and use the
same strategy on spy. Has about the same
win rate. Uh, low form first, high form
second. Spy actually went took it on
Friday. Q's did not. You can also go and
use it on gold. Uh, something
significant that I found for gold as
well is if you look at the report on I
believe it's a Thursday,
Thursday or Wednesday, one of the two.
Let me find it real quick. So, it's not
a Thursday.
Maybe on a Wednesday.
So, on Wednesdays, you're pretty much
either
when the high or lows form first, price
likes to go and take the high. I found
that last week uh last Wednesday
even though it had this range form kind
of disregards the high and low of that
range goes and breaks the high in most
cases. Uh this one has a 62% chance of
happening. This one has a 55 and a half%
chance. Hope you guys enjoyed the video.
Again, sorry for the voice cracks.
I'll I'll get another video released on
how I really go in depth on the data
with Edgeful just with the initial
balance report and initial balance by
rejection as well as the initial balance
by levels which is going to give you
your expansion targets.
So, I'll cover this in the next video
that I release.
Peace out. Happy holidays.
Enjoy your week.